thank you very much dr. Wolk I
appreciate this
thank you every wipe home on the left
side of my neck is about the size of a
pack of cigarettes of a surgeon who's
willing to take it out he tried to take
it out a year ago and he removed the
wrong one he's more than willing to do
this one except he's telling me I may
end up with nerve damage to my face I
was wondering if there's anything that
can help my body actually absorb this
and then eliminate it okay well the
first thing I would do is you know get
on the 90s injections if you're not
arguing at night I'm a few a sir yeah
come on what you ain't 140 pounds have
five-foot-five I'm sickening eight years
old okay okay very good
all right char here Steven he's 140
pounds five foot five sets about right
slim he's got like coma he's got a fatty
tumor on his neck and so what would you
give him to get his immune system to
help him here well I would give him a
healthy brain in her pack and I would
add I would add the ultimate daily
classic I would add the niacin plus and
also if it was a liquid antioxidant yeah
see radical theoretical you got let's
just do that let's start there and then
what would you put on top of you what
would you put on an anti-inflammatory
you can put on on top of the skin so
that it'll have some effect in helping
the body reduce the size of this lipoma
cream on well there you go you get an A+
tear and get yourself some Sam cream
apply that lavishly all over that lipoma
to three times a day and then what you
want to do is go to another
dermatologist at the other end of town
if you're near the University Medical
School go to the dermatologist Medical
School and let them examine to see for
sure what it is and ask them if they
could remove it and call us back and
tell us what they say